Smiles for the cameras but the tensions
remain France's interior Minister Gerard
darmana and his British counterpart sign
a deal to bring down the number of
dangerous boat Journeys across the
English Channel
it'll increase by around 15 percent the
amount of money the UK pays France each
year to Patrol its coast and try to stop
refugees getting into small dinghies
it'll also see British officers working
in French command centers and more
Technologies such as drones being used
we have some real winds for both the
French and the UK first of all we'll see
embedded observers that means there will
be British officers working on French
soil observing the work or working on
the ground with French officers to
detect and intercept the illegal
migrants as they attempt to leave France
this year more than 41 000 people have
reached England from France in small
boats compared with 28 and a half
thousand last year the increase is
putting pressure on places like the
manston processing center in Kent with
overcrowding and outbreaks of diseases
such as diphtheria
Sue Ella bravaman's recently spoken of
an invasion on the southern coast her
opponents accuse her of inciting hatred
and say the real crisis is one of the
home officers making
as of last month just four percent of
Asylum claims by people who crossed the
channel last year have been processed
and Britain's foreign secretary who
appeared before a parliamentary
committee on Monday has declined to say
how many Boat Crossings will be stopped
by the new Arrangements
some here in the UK point out the New
Deal says nothing about what happens to
the small boats once they're in the
channel or the idea of letting people
already in France apply for asylum in
the UK prime minister Rishi sunak says
dealing with the issue is a national
priority he's far from the first to do
so and he's unlikely to be the last
Nadine barber Al Jazeera London